im konjunkturpaket stecken übrigens
wollen wir nicht verschweigen auch noch
50 milliarden für zukunftstechnologie
also für wasserstoff forschung zum
beispiel wahrscheinlich flug taxis
laserschwerter in solche sachen
es wird also nach vorne geguckt passend
dazu beziehungsweise gar nicht passend
dazu ist letzten samstag ein nagelneues
kohlekraftwerk ans netz gegangen datteln
ja das macht total sind kohleausstieg
aber ein nagelneues steinkohlekraftwerk
für das die kohle wohl aus russland und
kolumbien importiert wird
nimm das weltklima seit anderthalb
jahren
trickett die groko schon an ihrem kohle
ausstiegsgesetz jetzt kann man nur beten
dass es so nicht kommt meint gernot
hassknecht gernot hassknecht präsentiert
deutsche berufe mit zukunft
heute wird man halo kids ich habe
umgeschult auf kohlekumpel macht ihr das
doch auch denn das hat voll zukunft
jedenfalls wenn unser bundestag echt so
blöd ist noch vor der sommerpause der
sogenannte kohle ausstiegs gesetz zu
verabschieden
ehrlicher wäre das alte schrottmeiler
noch jahrzehnte künstlich am leben halte
schwachmaten gesetz dies ende der 20er
jahre wird nämlich so gut wie gar nichts
abgeschaltet gegen alle empfehlungen der
kohle kommission ein einziger schlag ins
gesicht der jungen menschen dann ist
unsere zukunft und nicht die erwachsenen
menschen die jetzt auch schon irgendwann
sterben als erstens zweitens der junge
hat völlig recht
und jetzt lassen wir mal so
kleinigkeiten wie klima und das ende der
welt beiseite die blöde kohle ist
einfach nicht mehr rentabel
sogar das ist mittlerweile billiger als
die verstromung von kohle nach den
gesetzen des marktes müssten die meile
also sowieso bald vom netz gehen
allein den braunkohle prozent
entschädigen von 4,3 die jungen sind
hier total war eine rhetorische frage
ich gönne jedem kumpel seinen job aber
es wäre deutlich villiger jedem
einzelnen von denen einfach eine million
zu schenken die hätten es verdient
erschafft wer ist überhaupt noch so blöd
diesen unrentablen kohlestrom zu kaufen
[Musik]
die deutsche bahn muss wohl bald einen
großteil ihres stroms von datteln 4
kaufen
dazu haben sie sich in einem
langfristigen vertrag schon 2007
verpflichtet der inhalt ist geheim aber
da steht wo die deutsche bahn im
folgenden vollidiot genannt verpflichtet
sich bis zum sankt nimmerleinstag
überteuerten decks strom zu nehmen
glückwunsch aber hauptsache grüne
streifen am neuen ece donnerstag noch
habt ihr zeit dass kohle ausstiegs
gesetz zu überarbeiten
und wenn ich über arbeiten sage dann
meine ich denke an und nächste woche bei
deutsche berufe mit zukunft das mache
laternen anzünder und natürlich
walfänger auf bachelor innovation made
in germany
glückauf der steiger geht es eher looser
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was denn die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]